what should we leave for future
generations
most people agree we ought to preserve
resources like the environment for the
future but we're not very good at it why
is that how can we better cooperate with
generations that follow us
traditionally economists have assumed in
their models that we're mostly rational
and selfish most public policies try to
get selfish people to behave for the
overall good for example being rewarded
for reusing your plastic bags or having
to pay if you want a new one but there's
evidence that we're willing to cooperate
for the greater good if others do too
a team from Harvard put this to the test
they recruited several generations of
players for an online game each
generation had five members and a
hundred units to share if more than half
were left the resource made it through
to the next generation and was renewed
to a hundred the team tried a couple of
different things if people were allowed
to make their own decisions about how
much to take from the pool the resource
didn't last to the next generation
usually it was just one or two big
takers who were responsible then the
researchers tried a different version of
the game this time the five members
voted on how much to take and each
member got to take home the average
voting like this goes against selfish
interests and in favor of future
generations who the voters will never
meet by the way no players were related
the resource was sustainable in some
games the resource lasted for 14
generations but it only works if
everyone votes in another variation of
the game when only a few people voted
and the others chose freely the pool was
depleted voting works the authors say
because the majority of cooperative
types can restrain the grabbers and also
because the co-operators are reassured
that their efforts are not in vain
nobody wants to be the sucker so how can
government's take advantage of our warm
and cooperative feelings towards future
generations
well our cooperative nature can only be
harnessed if the vote is binding which
is why non-binding agreements like the
Kyoto Protocol on carbon emissions have
little power international politics is
never going to be easy so next the team
plan to explore how residents of
different countries play the game to see
if culture influences cooperation
in the meantime the idea might work best
on a more local level for instance if
every fisherman in a given area votes on
a maximum catch per day and everyone is
held to account the community has a
better shot at preserving fish stocks
for the future the study provides
evidence for a capacity that many have
hoped humans are capable of it was
Albert Einstein who said nothing truly
valuable can be achieved except by the
unselfish cooperation of many
individuals
you
you